[Musique]
que fait le chef de file de l'action
sociale à des moments clé de notre
développement
le département rassemble à l'hémicycle
tous les acteurs qui s'occupe des
personnes âgées afin de parler ensemble
d'avenir et ils étaient nombreux à être
attentifs à cet état des lieux objectif
commandé par la collectivité
je donne simplement et chiffres le ccas
du tampon gère un service d
accompagnement à domicile
quand nous regardons tous les ans notre
rapport annuel d'activité on constate
sur les trois dernières années une
augmentation de plus de 20 % de notre
activité non qui vous montrent que le
vieillissement est à notre porte
c'est déjà notre réalité là depuis trois
ans et si on n'y prend pas garde
toutes les solutions aujourd'hui qui
existent risque d'être rapidement
dépassé un développement accompagné sur
le plan national mais les chiffres
montrent clairement des différences et
des spécificités le maintien à domicile
en fait partie tout comme la solidarité
sociale
pour exemple 600 familles d'accueil sont
agréés localement une diversité des
offres qui doit correspondre à
l'évolution des publics
ils vont changer de prise en charge et
vont changer de modalités de de
ressources
certains sont en en secteur médico
social pour adultes handicapés vont
passer en ehpad
donc tous ces changements statutaires
donc de prise en charge la personne par
rapport à ces besoins qui vont évoluer
sont des éléments qui sont nécessaires
dans la prise en compte de ces
paramètres là dans la politique publique
chaque sly de cette présentation
lens à l'heure les alertes mais aussi
les perspectives pour les dix mille
personnes qui travaillent aujourd'hui
auprès des personnes âgées
vous voyez quand la population des
personnes âgées va doubler eh bien il
faut anticiper
il faut penser qu' on aura besoin
d'emplois d'employés de personnes
capables de travailler avec les
personnes âgées
que ce soit en établissement ou même
chez elle dans des associations dont des
institutions et donc là sylvain économie
ce sont des emplois pour lutter contre
la fracture numérique
ce sont des emplois bois accompagné donc
des aidants familiaux
ce sont des emplois dans les
établissements tout ce ce doublement de
la population va permettre de créer des
emplois à la règle le département
consacre 100 millions d'euros aux
personnes âgées
ainsi aujourd'hui est ensemble se
décident de quelle manière nos gramounes
vivront demain sur notre territoire
[Musique]